what is life
what is non-life what is the line
between life and non-life and maybe at
any point we can pull in ideas of
assembly theory
like how do we start to try to define
life and for people
listening so sarah
identifies as a physicist and lee
identifies as a chemist of course they
are very interdisciplinary in nature in
general but um
so what is life
yeah
yeah i love asking that question because
it's so absurdly big i know i love it um
it's my absolute favorite question the
whole universe um so i think i have
three ways of describing it right now um
and i like to say all three of them
because people latch on to different
facets of them and so the whole idea of
of what lia and i are trying to work on
is not to try to define life but to try
to find a more fundamental theory that
explains what the phenomena we call life
and then it should explain certain
attributes and you end up having a
really different framing than way people
usually talk so the way i i talk about
it three different ways
um life is how information structures
matter across space and time
um life is uh
i don't know
this one's from you actually simple
machines constructing more complex
machines
um and the other one is the physics of
existence so to speak which is
life is the mechanism the universe has
to explore the space of what's possible
um that's my favorite
so can i yeah yeah can i add on to that
okay can you say the physics one again
uh oh the physics of existence yeah the
physics of existence i don't know what
to call it you know like if you think of
all the things that could exist only
certain things do exist and i think life
is basically the universe's mechanism of
bringing things into physically existing
in the in the moment now
yeah
yeah what's what's another one
we were debating this the other day so
if you think about universe that has
nothing in it
that's kind of hard to conceive of right
because and this is where physicists
really go wrong they think of a universe
with nothing in it they can't and you
think non-existence is really hard to
think
yeah and then you think of the universe
with everything in it
that's really hard and and you just you
just have this white blob right this is
everything but the fact we have to
discrete stuff in the universe beyonce
planet so you've got star space planet
stuff right the boring stuff
but i would define life or say that life
is where
there are architectures any
architectures and we should stop
fixating on
what the bill is building the
architectures to start with and the fact
that the universe has discrete things in
it is completely mind-blowing
if you think about it for one second
the fact that there's any objects at all
that and there's because for me the the
object is a proxy for a machine that
built it some information
um being moved around
actuation sensing
getting resource and building these
objects so for me everyone's been
obsessing about the machine
but i'm like forget the machine let's
see the objects the you know and i think
in a way that assembly theory
we realized maybe a few months ago that
assembly theory actually does
account for the soul and the objects not
mystically like say sheldrick's morphic
resonance or leibniz's monodology seeing
souls and things but when you see an
object and i've said this before but
this object is evidence of thought
and then there's a lineage of those
objects so i think what is fascinating
is
that um
you put it much more elegantly but but
the barrier between life and non-life is
accruing enough memories to then actuate
so
so what that means is there are
contingency there are things that happen
in the universe get trapped these
memories then have a causal effect on
the future
and then when you get those concentrated
in a machine and you're actually able in
real time able to integrate
the past
the present with the future and do stuff
that's when you are most alive
are you being the machine yes wait a
minute why is the object so one one of
the ways to define life uh that sarah
said
is simple machines creating complex
machines
so
there's a million questions there so how
how the hell does a simple machine
create a complex machine
mutation so this is what we're talking
about the beginnings you have the
minimum replicator that's the molecule
so this is what i was trying to convince
sarah if the mechanism get there years
ago i think but then you've been
building on it and saying
you have a small you have a molecule
that can copy itself
but then that be a has there has to be
some variability otherwise it's not
going to get more functional so you need
to add bits on so you have a minimum
molecule that can copy itself but then
it can add bits on and that can be
copied as well and those add-ons can
give you additional function um
to be able to acquire more stuff to
exist
so existence is weird
but the fact that there is existence is
why there is life and that's why i
realized a few days ago
that there must be that's why alien life
must be everywhere
because there is existence is there like
a conservation
of cheeky stuff
happening so like how can you keep
injecting more complex things
like um doesn't the machine that creates
the object need to be
as or more compl more
powerful than the things it creates
so how can you get complexity from
simplicity
so the way you get complexity from
simplicity is that you
i would this i'm just making this up but
this is kind of my notion that you have
a large volume of stuff so you're able
to get um
seeds if you like random
cues from the environment so you just
use those objects to basically write on
your tape ones and zeros whatever
and that is that is necessarily rich
complex
okay but it has a low assembliness but
even though it has a high assembly
number i mean talk about that but then
when you start to then integrate that
all into a smaller volume as over time
and you become more autonomous
you then make the transition i don't
know what you think about that i think
the easiest way
to think about it is actually which i
know is a concept you hate but i also
hate which is entropy but people are
more familiar with entropy than what we
talk about in assembly theory
um and also the idea that like say
physics as we know it um involves
objects that don't exist across time or
as we would say low memory objects
um so one of the the key distinctions
that that low memory objects yeah so
physics is all physicists
physicists are creators of low memory
objects or manipulators of low memory
objects absolutely it's a very nice way
putting it okay sorry guys
sorry to keep in trouble no it's fine um
i like it too it's very funny um but i
think it's a good way of phrasing it
because i i think you know this kind of
idea we have in assembly theory is that
um
you know physics as we know it has
basically removed time as being a
physical observable of an object and the
argument i would make is that when you
look at things like water bottles or us
we're actually
things that exist that have a large
extent in time so we actually have a
physical size and time and we measure
that with something called the assembly
index
in molecules
you